- '93!
That's like, before I was born.
(whimsical music)
- I am 20 years old.
- I am 21.
- I'm 20 years old.
- I am 21 years old.
- I think the first CD I
purchased was a Green Day one.
- Um, that's a tough one.
- Purchased?
- Honestly, I don't have that many CDs.
- It says iBook, I
don't know if it's like,
the original MacBook or what.
- It looks kind of
old-fashioned, a little.
It's like this thick.
- We're gonna burn this on here?
On this iBook?
Wow.
- [Voiceover] No, I have
not seen a iPod like that.
- First gen.
- I thought this was
like, camera equipment.
- The size of this.
- Oh my god, the click wheel is physical.
- And you want me to
copy one of these songs?
- Sheryl Crow, I know Sheryl Crow.
- Yo, Wayne's World.
- What's Wayne's World?
- Snoop Doggy Dogg.
- Dog-u-style?
Doggystyle. (laughs)
- Beck. Odelay.
- Yeah, I don't know what that is either.
- I don't know which song I
would rip out of any of these.
- Ah, let's do Matchbox 20.
- I'm just gonna go with
classic Sheryl Crow.
- How do you open it? (laughs)
(laughs)
- Okay, um...
- See, I'm doing pretty well so far.
- I guess I just drag and drop, right?
Onto the music section.
(buzzing)
- Do I just drag from
the track to the iPod?
Is that...
(buzzing)
- The CD's like, this is a CD file right?
So you gotta change it into something
that an iPod can read?
(chiming)
- So wait, is it not MP3s then?
- I use Spotify now, so
can I use Spotify for this?
- Got this.
Got this iBook.
(whimsical music)
(iTunes chimes)
- Oh, I love that sound when
it finishes (vocalizes chime)
- Matchbox 20.
- Manual labor.
- I don't even know what songs...
Is it on the back?
Of the case, ah.
- There you go, I think I did it.
- It says "do not disconnect,"
so that means it's working.
- Even the cable is like, so big.
Everything is so clunky and weird.
- It's not even touch screen.
- Wait, what?
- Yeah, it's on. (laughs)
But I don't even like Snoop Dogg. (laughs)
- Yeah, it works.
- How old is this iPod?
- Yeah, it's good.
- I actually think my dad still has his.
- Deserves to be behind
some glass, you know.
- I'm all for vintage, but I don't think
I would carry this around with
me unfortunately. (laughs)